Lindsay and Berk is director for the
center of Education for policy and the
wolf Gilman fellow in education at the
Heritage Foundation she received her BA
from Holland University and an MA from
the University of Virginia MS Burke is
currently a PhD candidate in education
policy at George Mason University she is
the recipient of the W Glenn and Rita
Ricardo Campbell Award for her work on
choice and education she has testified
before Congress on education policy and
has published evaluations of education
choice options for public policy
foundations such as the Virginia
Institute for Public Policy in ed choice
she has done extensive work developing
and evaluating education savings
accounts she has written on education
reform for numerous publications
including The Washington Times National
Review in the Detroit News please join
me in welcoming Lindsey Ann Burke to the
podium
[Applause]
great well thank you all so much for
being here it's really just an honor to
be here at Hillsdale to speak at the
markets and policy seminar it's really
my pleasure it's the first time that
I've been out to Hillsdale so it's
really just a beautiful campus the
drive-in was beautiful
the leaves were changing everything was
just gorgeous
so really really happy to be here so I
want to take a little time today to talk
a little bit about the current state of
k-12 education in America particularly
how we got to where we are today with
the growing and I would say probably
galloping federal intervention in
education over the past half-century and
what that has meant both for k-12
education but also I'd like to talk just
a little about higher education policy
as well to round it out so first why do
we pursue education it's a big question
what do we hope education will imparts
to future generations
education is viewed as a means to
achieving important ends education as a
means for fostering upward mobility
instilling Civic values in gendering in
appreciation for the Arts and Humanities
even strengthening national security and
imparting students with the knowledge
and skills necessary to pursue their
life and career goals at its essence
education is seen as the vehicle through
which the individual is able to achieve
his highest aspirations and in so doing
elevates society and nudges human
progress forward yet progress in k-12
education and attainment has been
stagnant for at least two half-century
it jeopardizes the chances that public
education can deliver on the
expectations of the American people a
few examples among eighth graders just
34% of American eighth graders
proficient in reading that was in 2015
with proficiency rates declining
significantly for black and Hispanic
students - 16 % and 21 percent
proficient respectively data from the US
Department of Education long-term trend
assessment show that reading and
mathematics achievement has largely
stagnated over the past half-century in
fact reading and mathematics achievement
is no better today than it was in the
1970s when the US Department of
Education first began tracking those
data suboptimal achievement and
attainment are situated within decades
of k-12 education reform efforts the
launch of the Sputnik satellite awakened
an America that had until that point
felt technologically superior to its
Russian cold war allies the launch of
the first Earth orbiting satellites
spurred the Eisenhower administration to
pursue new federal investment and higher
education in particular resulting in the
passage of the 1958 National Defense
Education Act a law intended to rectify
a perceived shortage of mathematics and
mathematics experts and scientists
through access to federal student loans
for higher education
although the NDAA provided funding for
higher education title 2 of the law also
provided funding to state education
agencies to increase instruction in
modern foreign languages and to
strengthen math and science instruction
so the NDAA
really was the first considerable for a
on the part of the federal government
into k-12 education and it laid the
groundwork for the additional federal
intervention that would come about a
decade later
under the Elementary and Secondary
Education Act ESEA with the passage of
ESEA the federal focus quickly shifted
from addressing perceived national
security threats to improving
educational outcomes for disadvantaged
children President Lyndon Johnson
signing ESEA into law stated that his
intention was quote to bridge the gap
between helplessness and hope so lofty
lofty aspirations and ESEA ESEA
contained provisions providing financial
assistance to low-income school
districts school library resources
funding for education research and
grants to strengthen State Department's
of Education but it was just 32 pages
long you could get a staple through it
that original ESEA
right there are no federal laws that you
can get a staple through today I promise
you but after seven reauthorizations of
the original ESEA throughout the 1970s
throughout the 1980s into the 90s and
then culminating with No Child Left
Behind in 2001 and now its most recent
successor the every student succeeds act
we saw more and more federal spending
added to the original ESEA to finance
more and more federal programs in the
labyrinth that had been created within
that law federal intervention and
education really reached a high-water
mark with No Child Left Behind when for
the first time federal policymakers
began dictating to States the frequency
with which they would have to test
children so No Child Left Behind told
States that every student every year in
grades three through eight and then
again in high school would have to be
tested in core subjects and it adhered
sanctions to schools that failed to make
what they deemed adequate yearly
progress so it was significant new
federal intervention and local school
policy but state and district level
reforms actually paralleled those
federal reforms over the past
half-century states tried to improve
academic outcomes from the mid 20th
century onward policymakers introduced a
wave of reform in the states Epping and
flowing between policies rooted in
theories of constructivism such as the
creation of open classrooms to top-down
approaches that included teacher
professionalization efforts and the
growth of university based schools of
Education education reform
appearance a marked shift toward
outcomes-based reform during the 1980s
and continuing through the 1990s so that
shift from input space reform so
increased per pupil spending increased
efforts at curriculum and instruction
reform shifted significantly to outcomes
based reform and that was a response
largely in the 1980s to a sense that
particularly in the wake of the 1983
nation at risk report that American
education was pretty mediocre and in
fact the famous line from that report
was if an unfriendly foreign power had
attempted to impose on America the
mediocre educational performance that
exists today we would have viewed it as
an act of war and that those were strong
words in a federal education document
but despite these many federal and state
based education reform efforts from the
mid 20th century onward educational
outcomes have remained middling to say
the least some scholars have noted that
there has been a considerable
productivity decline in America's
schools American 15 year olds ranked
25th 24th and 40th in science reading
and mathematics achievement respectively
on the 2015 program for International
Student Assessment the Pisa exam and
that's an exam that compares outcomes
among OECD countries wealthier nations
as Stanford economist Carolyn Huxley has
found school math productivity decline
55% between 1970 and 1998 reading
productivity declined 73 percent over
that same time period at the same time
though federal state and local
expenditures total inflation adjusted
spending nearly tripled per pupil during
that time period from about 4,500
dollars in 1965 the Year Johnson signed
that original ESEA into law to about
$12,500 by the 2013 school year
although differing and approached these
various
form efforts whether federal or state
level were each designed to try to
improve outcomes within a district based
system which i think is at the core of
the problem indeed today families across
America have only two ways to exercise
school choice they can either be wealthy
enough to pay tuition out of pocket and
their local property taxes to support
their district school or they can be
wealthy enough to buy a home in an
affluent school district this isn't a
new phenomenon at all but that I cata me
between the educational haves and
have-nots has been magnified as
Americans watched their education system
leave them in the middle of the pack
internationally as they watch
generations of students being left
behind I think that we should be up in
arms about the fact that just a third of
high school seniors graduate reading
proficiently a third economist Milton
Friedman recognized this problem early
on he recognized the urgency of the
situation all the way back in 1955 when
he first proposed that the public
financing of education should be
separated from its delivery he made
rational compelling arguments for why
government funding of education does not
necessitate government administration of
schooling and operationalized that idea
in 1955 through the school voucher
concept where parents could use a
voucher to pay tuition at a private
school of choice
Friedman's voucher idea though would
effectively remain an academic idea from
about 1955 until 1990 when we saw the
introduction of the first modern day
school choice program in Milwaukee
Wisconsin Milwaukee introduced the first
voucher in the country letting the
choice and competition genie out of the
bottle and today there are more than 60
private school choice programs so
vouchers tax credit scholarships and
education savings accounts operating and
more than half of all states today
but what is remarkable to me is that
Milton Friedman kept refining this
voucher idea decades after he originally
first conceived it his latest 2003 he
gave an interview to the journal
education next in which he said there's
no reason to expect that the future
market will have the shape or the form
that the present market has how do we
know he asked how education will develop
why is it sensible for a child to get
all of his schooling in one
brick-and-mortar school why not let them
spend part of a voucher on math in one
place and part of it on English or
science somewhere else
why can't a student take lessons at home
especially now with the availability of
the Internet Friedman wondered and that
little gym that he left in that
interview in education next laid the
groundwork for a complete Rican Sepp
xual ization of how k-12 education is
financed it forced us to rethink at the
most basic level how we fund k-12
education and critically it led to the
introduction of edge of Education
savings accounts or ES A's
as some observers have noted if a school
voucher is similar to a coupon to pay
tuition at a single private school of
choice and education savings account is
like an Amazon giftcard you can still
pay that private school tuition but a
student can pay for myriad ancillary
education services with that debit card
that education savings account Arizona
became the first state to adopt an ESA
model and they did it back in 2011 and
today six states now have ESA options in
place so how does it work exactly if you
look at the Arizona model again they
started it in 2011 an eligible student
first choses to exit the district system
the public school the parents then
receive 90% of what the state would have
spent on that child in a public school
and it gets deposited directly into
their education savings account once
those funds are deposited into an ESA
goes on to a restricted
use debit card parents Canon use those
funds to pay for any education related
service product or provider so they can
pay for private school tuition textbooks
curricular materials private tutoring
special education services and therapies
if their child needs that they can pay
for online courses they can pay for
individual courses at a public school or
a public charter school they can pay for
a host of other education related
services and products and providers but
notably and the real critical refinement
from the school voucher concept is that
you can roll over unused esa dollars a
year to year so I had the chance just to
put a punctuation mark on how
interesting this is I had a chance to
meet some families in Arizona who are
benefiting from the ESA option and one
of those families were the Aston's and
their son Max Ashton great guy he's been
blind since birth and when the education
savings account option came on board he
decided to take advantage of it and his
family they'll tell you they'll be the
first to say the public school was
working ok for max they didn't have
major complaints but they decided to
give it a try and see how it would work
and so max exited the public system and
got his 90% of what the state would have
spent on him in the public school
deposited straight into his ESA it
literally goes onto a debit card that a
parent controls the state per pupil
dollars max was then able to which for
them since he was a blind student was
twenty thousand dollars a year and
remember that's just ninety percent so
max was then able to pay his private
school tuition at Brophy Academy in
Arizona a wonderful private school and
then was able to buy everything else
that he needed to be successful all of
his Braille textbooks and assistive
technologies a talking computer
everything that as a blind student he
needed to support him they were able to
do all of that and they still had
thousands of dollars left over at the
end of every year that they were able to
roll over max now uses
left over state es $1 to pay for his
college tuition at Loyola Marymount
University in California I mean to me
that is just an incredible way to
rethink how we deliver k-12 education
it's his left over state es $1 from
Arizona that he is now using in
California and I think it really
demonstrates how putting parents in the
driver's seat of their children's
education can go a really long way and
ensuring that families both get a good
value and get an option that works for
them
so why does it work that way why is it
so effective here again I think Milton
Friedman has a great answer to that and
he really had the foresight to push for
parent controlled education spending
Milton Friedman had a great framework
for in general how one might spend money
he said there are four ways that you can
spend money you can spend your own money
on yourself you can spend your own money
on someone else
you can spend someone else's money on
yourself or you can spend somebody
else's money on somebody else now you
can think about how this might apply to
k-12 education public schools spend
money in that last category category for
Friedman called it public schools by
their very nature spend somebody else's
money your taxpayer dollars on somebody
else's children so they have very little
incentive either to economize or to
maximize value education savings
accounts while admittedly are still
those public funds get at us much closer
to that category one spending much more
like spending your own money and it's
certainly spending it on your own
children and so you have every incentive
to economize and to maximize value but
education choice of course is about far
more than economic incentives I think
the economics are very important that
four ways to spend money I think really
does drive home how valuable and how
economized we can make k-12 education
when we put decisions in the hands of
the people who are closest
to the children those decisions affect
but it is about more than just economic
incentives we know that choice improves
academic outcomes for both school choice
participants and non-participants and
that it improves a student's chances of
graduating high school but it also
increases their likelihood of attending
and persisting through college it
decreases their likelihood of being
involved in criminal activity and it
improves their earnings potential and it
leads to parents who are more satisfied
with their child's education and other
words the benefits of school choice
accrue to some of the most important
aspects of our lives and it bears out in
the research to date researchers have
conducted 20 randomized control trial
evaluations of the impact of school
choice on academic achievement and
attainment among the RCTs conducted to
date 17 of those have studied the impact
of school choice on academic achievement
and of course randomized control trials
are important they are the gold standard
for assessing the impact of many
interventions certainly education
interventions
since chance determines which students
receive access to a given intervention
in this case school choice among the 17
randomized control trial evaluations
that are out there examining the impact
of school choice on academic achievement
11 of those 17 have found positive
impacts for some or for all students on
academic achievement four of those
evaluations found null effects so no
impact as a result of access to choice
such as a school voucher option and then
to have actually found negative effects
as a result of access to a school
voucher option we could talk a lot about
why that might be the case but the
evidence suggests it was the unique
regulatory environments in which these
school voucher options were operating
that may have caused the negative
effects to accrue in those two studies
but researchers have also conducted
three RCTs on
impact of Education choice on academic
attainment so on graduation rates all
three found statistically significant
improvements in graduation rates as a
direct result of access to choice and
I'll just note in Washington DC we have
a school voucher program and operation
there it had been under a pretty severe
threat for the past eight years during
the Obama years but either way the the
program's now on pretty solid footing
but that program in DC I would argue
it's probably one of the only federal
education programs it has ever really
worked but we found a 21 percentage
point increase in graduation rates among
participants in the DC Opportunity
Scholarship Program their voucher
program there and when I say we it was
the US Department of Education who found
that significant impact on graduation
rates in DC and yet we saw this program
under threats for like I said the past
eight years but it has since been put on
solid footing and we hope to see that
expand it moving forward so how the
school choice creates these fantastic I
would argue impacts on academic
achievement and attainment it does it I
would argue by putting decision making
in hands of the people who have the
contextual information necessary to know
what works for children and that's their
parents who are experts and their needs
school choice creates these benefits by
also making providers responsive to
parents as Jason Bedrich has written
real accountability means being directly
accountable to those who bear the
consequences of your performance school
choice generally and education savings
accounts in particular are about holding
providers directly accountable to
parents and there there's a good reason
why this works out this way it is
because a private school is a community
that Orient's itself around a common
purpose private schools are often built
around a belief system and even a code
of conduct some private schools have a
mission to provide education to students
of a single
sex so all girls are all boys schools
others organized around a certain
pedagogy Montessori education for
example and some are designed to serve
only children with specific special
needs such as schools that educate
children with autism others still
provide religious instruction that is at
the core of their mission to provide
perhaps a Catholic education so private
schools are communities that are built
around a common belief system
intentional communities students are
able to select into these schools
because they are well matched to their
individual needs and we have long
recognized that this is something that
heritage has fought for since our
founding in 1973 we have always
advocated for parents to be in the
driver's seat of their children's
education we have and we have also
worked at the same time and this often
gets left out of the equation to ensure
that taxpayers actually have a voice
when Washington tries to accelerate the
education spending spree and we are
seeing progress as I mentioned earlier
we're seeing growth and choice in 2000
there were just four school choice
programs in operation across the entire
country and today like I said there are
more than 60 and operation across the
states so there's been incredible
progress over the past decade and a half
but that also means that the tenants of
the debate have shifted a little bit of
course we still have to make the case
for choice for empowering parents for
moving from systems that resemble
monopolies to systems that as Milton
Friedman said allow families to be free
to choose but those who work on
education also know that they are in the
enviable position of debating not
whether there will be school choice but
best practices and program design
discussions about the size and scope of
these options creating a friendly
regulatory environment that allows a
market of providers to flourish and
debates about whether families will use
their choice that a single private
school of choice or to completely
customize their children's education and
that is a good problem to have we have
made major progress
my hope is that one day and the
not-too-distant future we will marvel at
the fact that we once assigned children
to government-run schools consigning the
poorest two schools that were often
failing and sometimes unsafe that we
will be astounded by the fact that at
the same time technology and choice
enabled Americans to have food and car
rides and entertainment at the touch of
a button on your cell phone that at the
same time an impoverished child in India
could learn physics virtually from a
tutor in England that at the same time
we had options like Khan Academy in k-12
ink that we still operated schools in a
brick and mortar assignment by zip code
model that moves children along and
batches in a factory type system and
that we assign children to those schools
based on where their parents could
afford to buy a home I think soon we
will marvel at that anachronism but in
order to ensure that children have
access to the highest quality options
that meet their unique learning needs we
have to rethink the problem of public
financing of education and how those
dollars are currently directed public
funding as I said earlier does not have
to mean government delivery of schooling
indeed we should as Friedman proposed
separate the financing from the delivery
of services instead of funding school
systems we should fund children and move
toward policies where dollars follow the
child to any education option of choice
work to advance educational opportunity
though cannot end at high school
graduation because the opportunities of
even those children who are graduating
at the top of their class are hampered
their life and career goals are hampered
by 1.3 going now on 1.4 trillion dollars
trillion in outstanding student loan
debt today higher education defined
broadly to include four-year colleges as
well as Career and Technical Education
and other individual coursework
should equip students with new skills
and no
should do that and it should do so
without saddling them or taxpayers with
significant debt burdens if we get
creative with the delivery of higher
education just as we have started to do
in a k-12 realm that's an entire
entirely achievable outcome massive open
online courses MOOCs are already
beginning to compete with non
consumption elite institutions like
Stanford and Harvard and of course
Hillsdale are already offering some of
the best academic content anywhere in
the world online you can learn to code
study statistics delve into Western
theology take coursework on economics or
game theory and learn Mandarin higher
learning is no longer confined to ivory
covered brick walls it is online anytime
anywhere to anyone our job now is to
help policy catch up with technology
just a few figures on the higher ed
situation at the moment during the
1970-71 academic year sixteen point five
billion that's inflation adjusted to
twenty fifteen dollars flowed from the
federal government through a handful of
federal student loan programs sixteen
point five billion now there are twice
as many federal aid programs and a
hundred and forty billion that we spend
annually on just student loans and
grants it's about two hundred and forty
billion when you include deductions and
other grants so during the 1992-93
school year only forty five percent a
full year's first-time undergrads use
any form of federal student aid
forty-five percent by 2011 that figure
had climbed to seventy-three percent of
all students accessing federal aid and
now the federal government originates
and manages over ninety percent of all
student loans today having nearly
completely crowded out the private
lending market has that made college
more affordable No
consider this during the 92 93 academic
year the inflation adjusts its sticker
price
of a four-year college was three
thousand nine hundred and ninety-eight
dollars that's inflation adjusted to
today's dollars which had risen to nine
thousand six hundred and fifty dollars
during the 2017-18 school year that's a
four year public institution one year
about nine thousand dollars now for a
private nonprofit 4-year institution the
sticker price was seventeen thousand
eight hundred dollars during the 1992-93
academic year
today it's about thirty three thousand
four hundred on average at a private
institution per year so no dumping money
out of helicopters as economists Richard
Vetter has said onto universities has
not encouraged them to keep keep cost in
check and the other problem is attached
to all of that aid are volumes of
federal rules and regulations which have
been increasing in size and scope over
the decades in order to keep college
costs in check
then we have to think about curtailing
over generous federal lending policies
in order to make space again for private
lending importantly federal loan
forgiveness must also be eliminated
period it's important I think to
remember that only one-third of
Americans today hold bachelor's degrees
so when the federal government is in
charge of ninety percent of all student
loans then taxpayers bear the burden for
loan forgiveness and for when students
default on their loans and of course
many of those taxpayers like I said do
not have college degrees themselves so
it is a terribly an equitable way to
think about how we finance higher
education we're shifting the burden of
paying for college from the student the
person who directly benefits to the two
thirds of Americans who don't have
bachelor's degrees themselves so how do
we start to wind down this federal bee
Emeth that exists in both k12 and higher
education today if three things that I
would suggest first allows States to
completely opt-out of the Elementary and
Secondary Education Act
so ESEA remember this was No Child Left
Behind just two years ago now we call it
the every student succeeds act states
should be able to opt completely out and
they should be able to put their dollars
toward any lawful education purpose
under state law I think that something
that often gets forgotten in the
conversation is that the federal
government is just a 10% stakeholder in
all k-12 education financing so states
and localities pay for 90% of everything
that we spend so allowing them to opt
out and to put those dollars toward
their local priorities should be a
priority of Congress and this is
something that has taken legislative
form over the past few years it's the
academic partnerships lead us to success
Act we have seen it reintroduced a few
times and actually during the height of
the debate over the rewrite of No Child
Left Behind about a year and a half ago
a plus got consideration for the first
time on the hill and I got a hundred and
ninety five votes and the first effort
ever to push that forward and so now a
plus really is I would argue the
conservative alternative to this
large-scale federal intervention through
essa but in addition to allowing States
to opt out to putting their dollars
towards state and local priorities we
should also think about and this is
where we have to be very careful
allowing the federal government to
advance some school choice options there
are I would argue very few vehicles at
the federal level that are appropriate
or wise to use to advance education
choice if you put a program at the
federal level there could be myriad
strings attached and you want those
programs situated as close to the
students they will affect as possible
however there are a few areas where the
federal government actually has a
constitutional warrant to advance an
education choice option and so thinking
about modernizing the existing dollars
that we spend in those areas and
transitioning those dollars into
education savings accounts to smart
policy one one option would be the money
that we spend right now for Native
American children living on tribal lands
there is a unique contractual obligation
with the federal government we should
modernize that funding and enable these
children to exit what are arguably the
worst schools in the country Bureau of
Indian Affairs schools there there
really it's a tragic situation so that
would be one option another option the
district of columbia is under the
jurisdiction of congress and we could
easily think about and it would be
entirely appropriate transitioning the
district into an all choice district and
enabling every single child in
washington DC to choose whatever school
works for them but we should also in
this last point is when I'm very excited
about on the federal school choice front
we should provide choice to children of
military families children of military
families sacrifice just as their parents
sacrifice and this is at this point a
retention issue we know that 35% of
active-duty families active duty members
have thought about leaving military
service altogether because of the public
school their child would have to attend
when they moved to a new duty station so
this is a retention issue but it's also
a national security issue we know that
only about a third of Americans today
who want to qualify for military service
could do so either because of a criminal
background lack of physical fitness or
their education level so it has bearing
both on the military today is a
retention issue and on the future
generations from whom we will be
recruiting so thinking about advancing
choices for military connected families
is a third piece that we think is
appropriate through federal policy and
finally the last thing that the federal
government really should do to start
divesting itself from all of its various
intervention from k12 through higher ed
is in the higher ed sphere to make space
for private lending and to think about
accreditation reform the federal
government should extricate itself from
higher education and in order to create
a private lending market that is
actually responsive to students and to
put downward pressure on higher
education prices
federal loans and grants should be
streamlined many of those loans should
be outright eliminated in order to
provide for a market of options that
will better meet the needs of students a
traditional four-year bachelor's degree
is the other critical piece of this this
puzzle we have made it such through
accreditation as it exists today that
for many people a traditional bachelor's
degree is the only path that seems
viable to upward mobility and it's a
great path but it shouldn't be the only
path for students there are many
students for whom alternative options
individual courses could really provide
them with the marketable skills needed
to enter a career right off the bat but
that requires eliminating what has
become a de facto federal system of
accreditation and allowing individual
options to accredit and credential
courses allowing Hillsdale to put its
seal of approval on an individual
theology class and allowing those those
student loans and grants to follow
through an individual course allowing
the Mayo Clinic to certify a nursing
course or bowing to certify an
aeronautical engineering course so
really infusing some market competition
and options within a higher education
realm but that requires decoupling
federal financing from accreditation so
those are the three big reforms that we
see as really a prerequisite to
eliminating or significantly limiting
federal intervention and local school
policy allowing States to opt out of the
Elementary and Secondary Education Act
advancing school choice in the few ways
that are appropriate and making space
for private lending through
accreditation reform so I'll conclude
with this there will never be at the
k-12 level this is particularly true
there will never be a better advocate
for a child than a parent and there will
never be a stronger form of
accountability than parents who are
empowered to vote with their feet when a
school or an education provider does not
meet their needs individuals must be
free to choose so they can be free to
learn education as we've written should
prepare individuals to inherit the
blessings and liberties of a free
society
curtailing government intervention and
education at all levels and putting
students and parents in the driver's
seat can ensure that it does just that
thank you
thank you miss Burke we now have time
for a few questions please raise your
hand and a microphone will be brought to
you thank you so much for coming miss
Burke the problem with implementing a
school choice program is that as long as
government funds are going to a
individual program the taxpayer in the
state has an interest in how those funds
are used so for example near where I
live there's a ghoul inist school a
school that's teaching based on a
Islamic Turkish cleric what would your
solution be to situations where school
choice programs are directing funds
towards institutions that may not have
the requisite ability to provide an
education or maybe teaching things that
serve to undermine the government of the
United States
sure so great question thank you for
that I'll start with your last piece on
this question of someone teaching
something that would undermine the
government of the US no school is
allowed to teach something like that
there are basic protections in place so
I think on that regard that choice
really isn't an issue schools are not
allowed to teach anything that would be
subversive to the to the government on
the first point though or your middle
point I think that it is important not
to compare education choice and what we
hope it could provide with some utopian
vision I think it's much more important
to compare with what we currently have
what we currently have is a system that
is failing thousands and thousands of
kids every single year and that is a
system that I would argue is not
accountable to anyone
I mean point to you know you can look at
schools across the country public
schools where reading proficiency rates
in some instances are literally in a
single digit single digits and kids are
graduating find me the administrator who
was held accountable for that right I
mean very rarely do we actually see
accountability and that's of course
because we know that schools district
schools get dollars no matter how well
or how poor
they perform and that is again because
of that assignment by zip code system so
we know at least from the literature
that choice does a better job than
assignment by zip code we know that
parents for the most part have what's in
their child's best interests and will
fight to the very last breath to make
sure that they're getting what works for
their children and you know combined
with choice options I think we are we
can expect to see some really wonderful
outcomes as a result but I would try to
compare it to what we currently have
versus what you know some utopian visit
of what it could be thank you so much
for coming out miss Burke it was really
a pleasure to talk with you I'd dinner
and I appreciate you sharing your
expertise with us as a native Arizonan
I'm very proud as you mentioned of the
wonderful steps that Arizona has taken
with school choice especially as a home
schooler and back in August there was
quite a bit of controversy over trying
to expand the ESA program and people
like senators WS Coe took a lot of heat
for trying to do this and the save our
schools Arizona which was a parent led
coalition was very much against this and
trying to get petitions to stop and send
it to the ballot and I really I'm trying
to understand why our parents who have
kids but especially those with the kids
in schools why would they be against ES
A's and how do we communicate that it's
actually their best interest that's such
a good question so how to say this so I
think that we should think about it as
maybe not necessarily being
representative of parents just as I
would say unions aren't necessarily
representative of teachers right so
unions tend to be representative of the
Union heads and that's about it right
the adults in the system with some of
these initiatives I would say it's also
the case with we're all sensibly parent
led groups but are really special
interest groups trying to stop choice
from spreading
I think the unions special interest
groups in general view choice correctly
is an existential threat to their model
to their power in public education and
so they have tried at every turn to stop
these options from proliferating and
you're absolutely right in Arizona now
Arizona as I mentioned home to the first
ever education savings account option
there is now a fight
in Arizona a ballot initiative that's
underway - long story short repeal the
expansion of the program that had been
in place the unions of course will dump
tons of money in a way that most groups
can't match in to this ballot initiative
so it is in a pretty tenuous position
right now if the ESA option gets bad
ballot outcome in Arizona it would only
repeal the expansion so the actual core
program still in place just quickly by
way of background when Arizona started
their ESA in 2011 it was only open to
kids with special needs but it was super
popular so then they expanded it to
military families children of fallen
soldiers children adopted out of the
foster system Native American children
their siblings so every year the program
expanded to more and more eligibility
pools this past year they expanded it to
be a universal option so every student
in Arizona if they wanted could access
an education savings account and that is
now what is under under attack and that
initiative so we'll see what happens
moving forward I would just add that
this has kind of been the story of
Education choice options is that they
tend to start small in the States
families get a taste of choice and then
we see it expand pretty rapidly one
exception to that was Nevada Nevada
introduced an ESA option a couple of
years ago now and they start it totally
Universal it was amazing it blew
everybody away they said every single
kid in Nevada if they want it can have
an esa four hundred and seventy three
thousand kids there is currently also a
legal battle playing out in nevada but
we hope that that will end up well and
will be really the first state with a
widespread universal education choice
option in place great question thank you
hi thank you for coming out to talk
today please correct me if I'm wrong
just it seems that you are intimating a
desire for a significant shift from
public school education to a diverse
array of private education options but
I'm wondering if you could speak on the
viability imprudence of greatly
improving our public school education
just because you know if the
institutions were founded and advocated
by our founders to educate the public at
large and so it just seems like there's
a great disparity and it would be
prudent to improve that to make public
schools a competitor to private
education as opposed to just sort of
shifting away from them of them entirely
yeah great question so to me this all
comes back to that Friedman esque notion
of just because we publicly financed it
doesn't mean it should be government
delivered so yes totally publicly
financed education but just allow those
dollars to follow a student so whatever
works for them so I wouldn't think about
it at all as undermining our public
education ideal it's just a situation
where we're deciding who's in a better
position to steward those dollars is it
a parent or is it a bureaucrat who's
never met the child who should be making
those decisions and I really believe
that we will strengthen public education
overall when we give some control to
families and we know this to some extent
we don't have a ton of evidence yet but
we know it to some extent with the
academic literature that's out there on
the competitive effects of education
choice programs so where we have seen
school choice options come into
existence and expand the nearby public
schools have upped their game because
they know that they can no longer just
rely on a steady stream of students no
matter how well or poorly they perform
and so what is beautiful about choice is
that empirically it has improved the
outcomes for both the kids who choose to
stay in the district system and those
who choose to exit the system and I
think that that's the other thing to
remember too you know a family will only
leave a public school traditional public
school if it's not meeting their needs
and if it's not meeting their needs I
would argue we shouldn't trap them there
so if public schools are being
responsive to families providing options
that work for them nothing to worry
about but even even beyond that though I
think it does get back to your original
question and it is just a matter of us
reconceptualizing
what public education means what do we
want to achieve through public education
we want an educated public we want a
public that is safe in school that has
civic values that appreciates everything
I mentioned before the arts and learning
generally and is prepared to pursue a
career inherit the blessings and
liberties of a free society we want all
of these things so the question is
what's the best way to ensure as many
students as possible can achieve those
ends and I would argue it's parents who
are empowered to choose options that
work for their children thank you
so my question regards the idea of
textbooks because currently right now
there's a lot of criticism about
textbooks and how they're being created
at least with the curriculums because
typically it's the school board state
boards of California and Texas that
drive what is in our in students
textbooks so how can these initiatives
help paint like the kind of monopoly on
what the curriculum is going to be
taught yeah it's a good question and I
hope that that's an additional benefit
that we see accrue from an education
savings account model in particular and
I know I probably sound like a broken
record talking about ESA is non-stop but
I genuinely believe that the power that
that has to really alleviate a lot of
these pressure points textbooks being a
really great example but just debate
generally about what's taught within a
district system to which a child is
assigned but you know you can imagine
and families are doing this we know by
the way about a third of families use
their es A's this way where you are
buying as a parent individual textbooks
or just books in general they don't have
to be textbooks you were by finding
curriculum that works maybe it's a great
books curriculum and then you were
hiring private tutors it was amazing we
were in Arizona again and watched a
student EJ what's-his-name about eight
years old has autism and he had been in
a district school and it was not working
for him at all he was having a terrible
experience and in fact his family moved
I think from Michigan incidentally to
Arizona to access the ESA option and it
was just so amazing to see EJ he
it's his I think it was math the day
that we we showed up the tutor comes to
his home it's regular tutor who he got
to know really well she gives the math
lesson mom pulls out her ESA debit card
the tutor pulls out her iPhone with the
square thing on top of it
mom swipes or ESA debit card pays the
tutor directly EJ gives her a hug and
she's on her way I mean it just it's
that type of customization so I think
whether it's textbooks or tutoring
whatever it ends up being that families
can pick down to the penny how they want
to spend every single dollar and I think
that the the benefits of that accrue to
a lot of other areas where there isn't
to your point a market there's much more
of a monopoly right now
hi I'm Dom Brimfield and I'm from
California
and I like what you're talking about in
general I think there's a a bridge here
though between the parents I agree that
parents should know the best thing and
what they want for their kids but we
have a moral deficit in America so I'm
not only sure that but I I do think that
there's a lot of situations where as
Abraham Lincoln said let's teach the
children so we don't have to teach the
adults we didn't do that
so now we have to teach the adults so if
you want to have a parent that can
decide what's best for their children
we might have to start by having the
parent and the child in the same hedge
academic educational setting for a while
until the parent can pick up their
education and then be able to know
what's best for their children
right and and I know that's difficult
but I live in a community where for
miles away there's a very deprived
economically deprived situation some of
those probably 50% of those parents can
neither read nor write very well maybe
they can sign their name and so how do
they know what's best for their children
we don't always know but I think there
should be some basic fundamental truths
of fact and education that we want all
schools to teach and these people be
brought up through that stream of
thinking and then they could be released
maybe to make better choices for their
children so that's a great comment
we give that comment a lot I have lots
of thoughts on that the first is that
choice I would argue will create a type
of standardization that you're looking
for in a way that we don't have it today
if you look at the charter school sector
that's a really good example of what I'm
talking about
so just like you know when you go to a
Burger King what a whopper and Baltimore
taste like is what a whopper is gonna
taste like in Texas you know when you
send your child to a Kipp charter school
that you're getting a pretty solid
Education Foundation you're gonna get
roughly the same Kipp experience and New
York as you do in Houston and that isn't
any sort of government mandate about
what Kipp teaches beyond the annual
testing but beyond that that is choice
that has created a level of
standardization that parents can then
opt into so I think we'll see a lot more
of that in terms of maybe a Americans
not being as whatever you would like
them to be generally this is again the
great thing about choice right it is
that idea that I mentioned earlier on
the competitive effects but this you
know to sound cliche this rising tide
that lifts all boats I don't have to be
an expert and I am definitely not an
expert and car-buying however I can talk
to my neighbors I can look at reports
whatever a car in Kelley Blue Book
whatever's out there and get both expert
feedback and peer to peer reviews about
what a good car is same thing with
restaurants when you go out I don't look
at the Michigan Health Department
website when I go to find a restaurant
maybe I should I don't know but I don't
look at the Michigan Health Department
website I look at Yelp and Urban Spoon
and I see what other people have said
about a restaurant how have they rated
it and in fact interesting little side
note on that I believe it was New York
but it was difficult for the health
inspectors to go around and rate all of
these restaurants all the time
consistently and so they start at
crowdsourcing information from Yelp and
from some of the restaurants that rate
restaurants and there was actually an
academic study out on this and that
Yelp reviews predict it perfectly
whether or not a restaurant would get a
bad health inspection rating or not and
so I mentioned that just to say the
types of nuanced information that a
market will provide you it will
certainly accrue to education I think we
are just so used to a hundred and fifty
years not quite actually a hundred years
or so of government delivered government
assigned schooling that it's just really
hard to break out of that mold and we
tried the standardization tests with
common core and that was that was no
good thank you
for Bowling Green Ohio and my state
senator says that it's very likely that
Ohio will will pass an ESA in the next
couple of years in Ohio did you mention
its property taxes I pay a local school
income tax and then there's money that
comes from the state if an ESA is ninety
percent or even a hundred percent of
what the state spends that's less than
fifty percent in the district as I am
from your perspective is that go to work
or is there gonna have to be other
sources of money yeah it's interesting
you would bring that up I actually wrote
a paper on that exact issue for the
Buckeye Institute in Ohio because they
are in fact looking at expanding an ESA
model in Ohio's home to quite a few
existing education choice options as it
is and so you know y'all are new to the
education choice model at all there are
different ways to think about it that
50% of the state per pupil could be one
funding source if you want to get really
crazy you can think about a tax credit
finance education savings account so if
you think about how a tax credit
scholarship works basically the output
is like a voucher but the input is an
individual or corporation contributing
to a non-profit the donor gets a dollar
for dollar tax credit and then a student
gets a scholarship to attend a private
school choice the output in that case
could be an education savings account so
you could even transition your existing
education choice options into an ESA
model as well so there I think there are
a couple different vehicles you could
pursue for making it viable but it is
it's tricky when you're in a state where
most of your revenue comes from local
property tax but it's not without
precedent entirely Douglas County
Colorado has the only district run
school choice program in the country
which has been really interesting
because it was their state school board
that actually created this program in
Colorado so there's some there are a few
different vehicles that are out there
for for doing an ESA in Ohio I'll send
you my report we have time for one more
question I may be repeating myself here
but I really wanted to support done berm
field because I think with the I can
hold it I think okay I I believe that
student or parents do know what's best
for their children in by and large but
there are and many of the people who've
taught school here certainly have
understood that there are many many
parents who do not necessarily know how
to help their kids so I guess I just am
seconding his comments and also the
young woman and back about public
schools do we really need to forget
about public schools or can we try to
improve them too and what you're saying
I'm not sure I understood exactly what
you're saying about how they would be
improved but I hope that's the case
I yeah I hope that's so it's appreciated
I think great notes to end on so on the
last piece of your question if I had my
druthers tomorrow every single child and
the entire country would be funded with
an education savings account and they
could then choose any option if they
want it to go to a brick-and-mortar
district run school that would be
wonderful but if they needed something
else they could choose it so that that's
how I would if we were starting from
scratch tomorrow I would fund the kid
instead of the physical plant that is
the school building but on the first
part of your question about parents you
know maybe some having difficulty
navigating a system of choice so I'll
give you one anecdote and you know not
data but an anecdote from DC
so there's a great small private
Christian school in DC cornerstone and
as I mentioned DC has a voucher program
it's been there since 2003 only
federally funded voucher program and
yeah we talked to the principal at
Cornerstone and he said you know I know
immediately oh and I should preface this
by saying the DC voucher is open only to
low income families so the median income
was $23,000 for a family of four last
year which let me tell you in DC is
nothing so these are the lowest income
families but the principal said I know
immediately when a parent from the DC
voucher program is calling on the phone
and looking for a school because they
have a checklist of things that they
want that ability to shop around they're
asking all kinds of questions about the
teacher the curriculum the pedagogy
extracurriculars the religious
instruction that's their school safety
so he said he knows immediately when
it's a voucher parent because they have
this shopping around checklist and this
is one of my favorite quotes from an
academic paper I hear I think that's
safe to say actually that I have a
favorite quote from an academic paper
not always safe but but one of my
favorite quotes was from Patrick wolf at
the University of Arkansas and he
actually conducted the random assignment
evaluations in DC of that program and he
said that what he found was that parents
moved from being passive recipients of
the public system to really active
participants that it moved them from the
margins to the center of their child's
academic experience and that just it
really resonated resonated with me and
it has been the experience we've seen on
the ground so you know yes there will
need to be some adjustment to a
widespread system of choice but I have
every confidence that it will be far
better in the long run than what we have
now great thank you
[Applause]